AND EMILY COMPAGNO.
THIS IS "THE FIVE" IN NEW YORK
CITY.
ALL EYES ON A KEY SWING STATE
TODAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND JOE BIDEN
ARE HOLDING DUELLING EVENT IN
MINNESOTA.
THE PRESIDENT IS HOPING TO TURN
THE STATE RED FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN DECADES AND JOE BIDEN IS
TRYING TO STOP HIM.
HERE’S THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
A FEW MINUTES AGO.
>> IN THE MIDST OF THIS
UNPRECEDENTED CRISIS, TRUMP HAS
GIVEN UP ON PRETENDING TO DO HIS
JOB.
AS THE PRESIDENT JUST STARTED A
WEEK EARLIER IN MARCH THAN HE
DID, WE WOULD HAVE 36,000 MORE
PEOPLE SITTING AT THE DINNER
TABLE TONIGHT.
HOW MANY PEOPLE ACROSS THE
TABLE?
HOW MANY EMPTY CHAIRS?
BECAUSE OF HIS NEGLIGENCE AND
SELFISHNESS.
>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SET
TO RESPOND WITH A GREAT AMERICAN
COMEBACK RALLY TONIGHT.
THIS COMES AS THEY STEP UP THE
INTENSITY OF ATTACK IN KEY
BATTLEGROUND STATES.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> IF BIDEN WINS, VERY SIMPLE,
CHINA WINS.
IF BIDEN WINS, THE MOB WINS.
IF BIDEN WINS, THE RIOTERS,
ANARCHISTS AND ARSONERS AND FLAG
BURNERS WIN.
>> IF THE PRESIDENT HAD DONE HIS
JOB FROM THE BEGINNING, ALL THE
PEOPLE WOULD STILL BE ALIVE.
THIS PRESIDENT SHOULD STEP DOWN.
>> JOE BIDEN DEVOTED HIS ENTIRE
CAREER TO OFFSHORING WISCONSIN
JOBS, OUTSOURCING YOUR
FACTORIES, THROWING OPEN YOUR
BORDERS.
>> REALLY DO SEE THIS CAMPAIGN
AS A CAMPAIGN BETWEEN SCRANTON
AND PARK AVENUE.
THE WAY WE WERE RAISED, A LOT OF
HARD-WORKING PEOPLE BUST THEIR
NECK.
THEY ASK FOR A SHOT.
ALL TRUMP CAN SEE FROM PARK
AVENUE IS WALL STREET.
>> Dana: JESSE, MAYBE START WITH
YOU.
IT’S FIFTH AVENUE, NOT PARK
AVENUE FOR FACT CHECKING HERE.
>> Jesse: YEAH.
YOU WERE THE ONLY PERSON TO FACT
CHECK JOE BIDEN, DANA.
HE GOT AWAY WITH A LOT OF
DOOZIES LAST NIGHT.
I DON’T KNOW.
I THINK MINNESOTA IS IN PLAY.
BIDEN IS GETTING SPREAD VERY
THIN.
HE HASN’T BEEN TO MINNESOTA IN
1,000 DAYS.
EVERY DAY HE HAS TO GO TO A
STATE LIKE MINNESOTA WHICH
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEES NEVER GO TO
IS A DAY HE’S NOT IN A STATE
LIKE FLORIDA.
LOOKS LIKE TRUMP IS DOING FIVE
RALLIES IN FIVE BATTLEGROUNDS IN
FIVE DAYS.
NOT ONLY THAT, THE WHOLE FAMILY
IS INVOLVED.
TRUMP JR. IS DOING FIVE
BATTLEGROUNDS IN FIVE.
EBB--  IVANKA IS DO FOR.
IT’S CLEAR JOE BIDEN WANTS TO
TALK ABOUT THE CORONAVIRUS.
RIGHT NOW, MINNESOTA IS
AVERAGING NINE DEATH AS DAY.
THAT’S NOT AS BIG OF AN ISSUE AS
THIS SUMMER.
THE PRESIDENT HAS PIVOTED TO THE
ECONOMY AND THAT’S GREAT.
THE ECONOMY IS IN A SUPER V AND
PREDICTING UNEMPLOYMENT AT 5%
NEXT SUMMER.
THAT IS THE FASTEST ECONOMIC
RECOVERY IN U.S. HISTORY.
I KNOW JUAN WANTS TO TALK ABOUT
THE CENSUS REPORT THAT JUST CAME
OUT.
JUAN, YOU CAN’T ARGUE WITH THESE
STATISTICS.
SO JUST SIT THERE AND LISTEN.
IN 2019, THE AVERAGE AMERICAN
HOUSEHOLD MADE AN EXTRA $4,400.
IT IS AN ALL-TIME HIGH NOW,
MEDIAN INCOME IS $68,000.
IN THREE YEARS, THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN FAMILY HAS MADE NEARLY
$9,000 MORE UNDER DONALD TRUMP.
UNDER BARACK OBAMA IN EIGHT
YEAR, THEY GOT A $1,000 RAISE.
INCOME AND EQUALITY IS NOW
SQUEEZING COMPARED TO OBAMA AND
BIDEN WHERE IT EXPANDED.
THE POVERTY RATE IS AT AN
ALL-TIME LOW.
FOUR MILLION PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
LIFTED OUT OF POVERTY UNDER
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT’S WHY THE PRESIDENT WILL
HAMMER THE ECONOMIC MESSAGE AND
THAT’S WHY HE WILL WIN.
>> Dana: JUAN, I’LL GIVE YOU A
CHANCE TO RESPOND.
I DID WANT TO ASK YOU A QUESTION
ABOUT MINNESOTA AND REPUBLICANS.
IS IT FOOL’S GOLD THE WAY TEXAS
IS FOR DEMOCRATS?
>> Juan: MINNESOTA, DANA?
>> Dana: YES.
>> Juan: BECAUSE I THINK I JUST
SAW THAT BIDEN IS UP TEN IN
MINNESOTA.
SO --
>> Dana: THAT’S WHAT I MEAN.
LET ME CLARIFY.
I SHOULD CLARIFY.
>> Dana: SO DEMOCRATS KEEP
SAYING THEY’RE GOING TO WIN
STATEWIDE RACES IN TEXAS.
THEY NEVER DO.
REPUBLICANS ARE TRYING TO WIN IN
MINNESOTA AND IT’S BEEN ELUSIVE
TO THEM.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS COME CLOSER
THAN MOST.
THIS TIME AROUND, YOU THINK THE
REPUBLICANS WILL FALL SHORT
AGAIN IN MINNESOTA?
>> Juan: WELL, YOU KNOW,
OBVIOUSLY THERE’S AN OPPORTUNITY
THERE GIVEN THE TROUBLE THAT
HAPPENED IN MINNEAPOLIS WITH
GEORGE FLOYD, AND WE’VE GONE
OVER SOME OF THE ISSUES LIKE THE
CITY COUNCIL GOING BACK AND
FORTH ON DEFUND OR REFORM THE
POLICE, HOWEVER YOU WANT TO PUT
THAT TOGETHER.
SO I THINK THAT THE PRESIDENT
MUST THINK THAT, YOU KNOW, THAT
MESSAGE ABOUT LAW AND ORDER AND
THE LIKE HAS SOME RESONANCE
THERE.
I DON’T KNOW IT’S WORKING GIVEN
WHAT I JUST SAID ABOUT THE
POLLS.
BUT I WANTED TO RESPOND TO JESSE
AS WELL AND SAY JESSE, I THINK
THERE’S A LOT OF AMERICANS THAT
ARE GOING THROUGH REAL ECONOMIC
PAIN RIGHT NOW.
A LOT OF THAT PAIN, THAT
ECONOMIC PAIN IN TERMS OF
UNEMPLOYMENT, SPECIFICALLY, IS
TIED DIRECTLY TO THE
CORONAVIRUS, AND WE KNOW FROM
THE PRESIDENT’S OWN WORDS THAT
HE WASN’T STRAIGHT WITH US --
>> Jesse: IT’S BECAUSE OF THE
SHUT DOWN.
NOT TIED TO THE VIRUS.
IT’S THE SHUT DOWN AND REOPENING
IT BACK UP.
>> Juan: I’M THINKING THAT WHEN
I LOOK AT OTHER COUNTRIES, OUR
PEERS IN THE WORLD, THEY HANDLED
IT BET EBB--
>> Jesse: THAT’S FALSE, JUAN.
>> Juan: OUR DEATH RATE IS MUCH
HIGHER THAN OTHER DEVELOPED
COUNTRIES.
WHAT I’M SAYING, AS WE AMERICANS
GET TOGETHER AND CRUSH THIS
CORONAVIRUS, WE CAN’T EXPECT
THAT OUR ECONOMY IS GOING TO
HAVE A RESURGENCE.
THAT MEANS WE CAN’T BE INVOLVED
IN POLITICIZING MASKS,
POLITICIZING WHEN A VACCINE IS
COMING.
WE CAN’T BE PUTTING PRESSURE ON
OUR CDC OFFICIALS AND TELLING
THEM OH, YEAH, YOU’RE WRONG
ABOUT WHEN THE VACCINE IS
COMING.
THAT HAS TO STOP.
I THINK AMERICANS SEE THAT.
>> Jesse: I AGREE.
LET’S NOT POLITICIZE IT.
>> Dana: THE POLITICS IS HERE.
GREG, LISTEN TO JOE BIDEN
TALKING ABOUT THE MASK MANDATE.
HE STILL IS TALKING ABOUT IT.
>> I’D LIKE TO SEE THE GOVERNORS
ENFORCE MASK WEARING, PERIOD.
I CAN DO THAT ON FEDERAL
PROPERTY.
AS PRESIDENT I’LL DO THAT.
WE CAN HAVE A FINE FOR THEM NOT
DOING IT.
THIS IS ABOUT SAVING LIVES.
>> Dana: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF HIM
NOT LANDING ON ONE CONSISTENT
MESSAGE?
>> Greg: THAT’S JOE, YOU KNOW?
HE WILL SAY WHATEVER SOMEBODY
WANTS HIM TO SAY.
IF HE REALIZES IT WASN’T THE
RIGHT THING, HE WILL CHANGE IT.
SOMEBODY DID FACT CHECK HIM.
JOHN CARNEY.
I THINK OVER AT BREITBART.
THAT QUESTION THAT JOE THINKS IS
SO CLEVER.
SCRANTON VERSUS PARK AVENUE.
HE’S RIGHT.
BUT PARK AVENUE SUPPORTS BIDEN
BY A FACTOR OF 8 TO 1 MARGIN.
RIGHT?
AND TRUMP GETS MORE MONEY FROM
SCRANTON THAN PARK AVENUE.
SO THAT’S A GOOD FACT CHECK.
I HAVE TO CREDIT JOHN CARNEY.
YOU KNOW, THE THING THAT HE
SAYS, IF WE STARTED A WEEK
EARLIER, WE WOULD HAVE SAVED
30,000 WEEKS.
WHY DOESN’T HE SAY A WEEK, TWO
WEEKS, THREE WEEKS?
DO THOSE LIVES NOT MATTER?
OR ARE WE STARTING TO GET INTO
DEEPER INTO THE IMPEACHMENT
TERRITORY WHERE WE KNEW THAT WE
HAD COMPLETELY MISSED THIS THING
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS ARE
OBSESSED WITH IMPEACHMENT?
IT’S FUNNY.
HE SAYS THAT TRUMP IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL THE DEATHS.
HE SAYS THAT DATA BACKS HIM UP.
THAT’S NOT TRUE.
JOE HAS TO BE SUPER CAREFUL
BECAUSE HE’S GOING TO RUN OUT OF
ROOM FOR FUTURE DEMONIZATION.
IF HE KEEPS MAKING IT BIGGER AND
BIGGER AND BIGGER, MAYBE DONALD
TRUMP NEXT WEEK WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR NOT ALL PAST
DEATHS BUT FUTURE DEATHS.
MAYBE HE CAN TAKE THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR KILLING JESUS
OR MLK.
THE DEMS HAVE HIT A LIMIT ON HOW
EVIL THEY CAN PORTRAY TRUMP.
THEY STOPPED COMPARING TRUMP TO
HITLER NOT BECAUSE IT WAS UNFAIR
TO TRUMP, THEY THOUGHT IT WAS
UNFAIR TO HITLER.
THEY THINK HE’S WORSE THAN
HITLER.
THIS HAVE -- IT’S GETTING TO A
POINT -- IT’S ALWAYS BEEN
HILARIOUS, WATCHING THEM CREATE
THESE EVIL FANTASIES.
I JUST WANT TO WONDER WHERE
THEY’RE GOING NEXT, DANA.
WHERE.
TELL ME.
>> Dana: ONCE YOU’VE GONE THERE,
THERE’S NO WHERE TO GO.
EMILY?
>> GREG, THERE’S NO LIMIT.
I’D LIKE TO ADDRESS THE CLIPS
THAT WE PLAYED IN THE BEGINNING
OF THIS SEGMENT.
WE KNOW THAT BIDEN PLAYS THE
UNION ANGLE.
THAT’S WHY THROUGHOUT HIS
CAREER, HE SET UP THE EVENTS.
SO HE RELIED ON THEM AS HIS
COMFORT ZONE.
WHILE HE’S PALLING AROUND WITH
THE UNION BOSSES, HE SHOULD BE
MORE CONCERNED WITH THE UNION
WORKERS.
WE KNOW THAT TRUMP CARRIED MORE
UNION WORKERS IN MINNESOTA IN
2016 THAN ANY REPUBLICAN SINCE
REAGAN.
HE’S DELIVERED ON THE PROMISES
THAT HE MADE TO THEM.
THIS ADMINISTRATION EXPEDITED
MINING CONTRACTS, WHICH IS
CRITICAL IN MINNESOTA.
HE RENEGOTIATED NAFTA.
MANY UNION MEMBERS ARE UPSET AND
CONCERNED ABOUT THE DIRECTION
THAT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
GOING WITH GUN CONTROL AND
OBVIOUSLY ENERGY.
QUICK FINAL POINT.
REMEMBER IN JULY WHEN BIDEN HELD
THAT VIRTUAL EVENT WITH
MINNESOTA UNION BOSSES.
A FEW DAYS AFTER HE RELEASED HIS
ENVIRONMENTAL PLAN.
THE UNION BOSSES CHEERED THE
PLAN.
A FEW DAYS LATER, THE WORKERS
WERE POLLED.
THEY SAID WHAT WAS MOST
IMPORTANT TO THEM IS STEADY
GOOD-PAYING JOBS.
WHAT IS GOOD PAYING JOBS TO
THEM?
THEY ASSOCIATE IT WITH
TRADITIONAL ENERGY AND